[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 30 novembre 2005 quand et
dans quel monde du travail est ce que
vous vivez
est ce que vous êtes sur la plage et
vous avez votre lot g qui est en réunion
est-ce que traille les robots je vous
laisse rêver quelques secondes
parce que moi mon rêve c'est justement
ici 2050 de changer le monde du travail
et pour changer ce monde du travail qui
est quand même assez ambitieux vous me
direz pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
commencer
j'irai d'abord pour faire changer les
choses comme ça a été dit dans les
présentations précédentes
effectivement on parle de jeunes gens
parlent de révolution
on parle de changement en parle de
leader dans ses effectifs en tout au
long de l'histoire c'était chaque fois
des leaders ont permis à l'histoire de
changer et ses leaders là doivent
pouvoir incarner une nouvelle culture
une nouvelle culture du travail et cette
culture c'est une culture différente
je sais pas certains d'entre vous rêvent
du camp l'ambition de devenir des
entrepreneurs ou de créer une équipe de
monter une équipe quelle qu'elle soit
moi ce que j'ai tendance à dire c'est si
c'est votre cas
ne regrettez pas des collaborateurs des
employés mais plutôt fonder une famille
en tout cas je me suis basé sur
mais dix quinze vingt ans même satané
l'entrepreneuriat et des quatre sociétés
j'ai pu créer pour arriver à un constat
en 2013 où j'ai créé ma dernière
entreprise
les premières personnes que j'ai fait
venir avec moi dans l' aventure c'était
deux meilleures années et évidemment
beaucoup de mes proches
on dit mais des fous recruter des amis
s'il ya un problème vous savez que
terminer avec votre amitié il faut pas
mélanger le travail l'amitié bon et
comme j'aime bien prendre le revers pas
forcément écouté en tout cas j'aime
toucher du doigt évidemment je les fais
maintenant ça fait 55 ans et demi c'est
un succès ça marche très bien et puis
quelques mois plus tard j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un qui m'a rejoint une dizaine de
jours après il m'a présenté sa femme
je me suis dit super et là évidemment
demande de ceux qui travaillent avec
nous mes amis ma famille m'a déconseillé
de le faire et m'a dit mais je sais je
t'imagine leur côté un trouble dans
l'entreprise ça ne se fait pas interdite
qui doit pas besoin comme j'aime bien
tester et l'interdît c'est un peu pas
peur au contraire
ceci dit je vais le faire et je l'étais
est-ce que ça a marché pas du tout mais
alors pas du tout m un beau fail et
avait tiré les conclusions
et puis trois mois plus tard une
opportunité se présente à moi rencontre
de personnes un couple et je me dis mais
ce serait super si vous venez travailler
avec moi il a évidemment toujours le
même personnel d'autres personnes mais
n'étaient pas sages été plantés il ya
quelques mois n'a pas réitéré la même
erreur qu'ils nous n'en met j'ai tiré
les leçons de ça et là du coup j'y
réfléchis demande du conseil mais je
vais quand même le faire et je les fais
et c'est le succès comme commençait une
jeune eu de gros n'a même rien c'est
vrai et intérêts ça a marché et
maintenant ça fait quasiment quatre en
quatre ans et demi que ça marche très
bien et puis six mois plus tard j'ai
dans ces nouveaux pays la belgique et
j'ai démarré avec différentes personnes
voilà qui ont rejoint notre famille
parce que j'ai l'habitude de dire quand
une grande famille et la bout de
quelques mois se présente on a quelqu'un
me rejoint revint notre mouvement
et puis j'ai dîné avec avec elle et son
mari
et puis là je me dis mais ce serait
super si nous rejoignent et là en cours
toujours les mêmes qui disent non il
faut pas le faire c'est bon on ne va pas
les entreprises skype des couples mais
non mais c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse ce
qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment la
personne il est compétent on se serait
super si nous rejoignent et puis est-ce
que je l'étais évidemment oui je les
paie et ça fait 3 ans 3 ans et demi que
ce succès ça marche très très bien et je
vais terminer par la dernière manière
éléments de l'anecdote c'est que six
mois plus tard j'ai lancé un nouveau
pays j'aime bien lancer de nouvelles
aventures de nouveaux pays ces deux
virus d'entrepreneuriat quand on est un
petit peu du mal à s'arrêter
et puis là donc je lance la hollande est
là et quelle opportunité s'offre à moi
laisse deviner non pas un couple c'est
bon mais couple la menace est par contre
là un père et son fils toujours un ami
histoire bus et des tracteurs qui me
disent de ne pas le faire et évidemment
c'est un succès depuis maintenant deux
ans de zinc
j'arrête là avec les histoires de pays
histoire de
de famille et de couple est en fait
aujourd'hui dans l'entreprise créée on y
plus de 500 dans le cinq six pays et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que j'ai
vraiment l'habitude de dire qu'on est
vraiment une grande famille au sens
figuré vraiment comme au sens propre
on trouve tous les liens de parenté chez
non on trouve des frères des soeurs des
cousins des coûts si donc moi même j'ai
envie elle ma fille elle qui sont avec
nous vraiment on trouve tous les biens
et en même temps ça ne me parle beaucoup
en général de cooptation que c'est
important que des entreprises ont
vraiment beaucoup de mal à recruter et
donc généralement ils vont utiliser le
levier de la cooptation c'est vrai que
c'est quand même assez fort la
cooptation c'est quelqu'un qui déjà dans
l'entreprise qui va les chercher une cni
un de ses collègues ou anciens collègues
pour le faire venir dans l'entreprise
dans laquelle il est carrément risque
est justement ce qui est intéressant
c'est que là on va encore plus loin
lorsqu'on dit comptait devenir des
membres de sa famille c'est que vraiment
on est engagé si on le veut du bien du
principe que de devenir membre de sa
famille chez moi c'est comme ça et donc
effectivement ça a été de créer sa est
en fait derrière la famille qu'est ce
qu'on va trouver
on va trouver un ensemble de valeurs
communes
on va trouver des rituels des rites
commun on va trouver on parlait tout à
l'heure de langage on va trouver un
langage commun aussi au sein de la même
taille et en fait c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de créer mais même gérer de
co-créer dans la mesure où je suis parti
du principe aussi que que la la
hiérarchie ep morte en tout cas
personnellement je ne crois plus à la
hiérarchie je reviens sur la famille est
ce que dans une famille on a des liens
de subordination est ce qu'on ait des
chefs
différents niveaux hiérarchiques non pas
du tout et même gérer en général le rôle
des parents
le rôle des plus anciens c'est justement
de faire grandir ses enfants de créer
l'environnement dans lequel chacun va
pouvoir s'épanouir de créer
l'environnement aussi dans lequel un
moment mais les enfants vont devenir les
adolescents vont devenir des adultes
plus des parents et donc eux-mêmes vont
être amenés à remplacer les autres les
plus anciens est vraiment toujours dans
le même esprit et donc au niveau
hiérarchique au niveau entreprise dont
cas pour moi c'est la même chose
je pense que on a en a assez des
hiérarchies ancien des pyramides
ça fait plusieurs décennies siècle au
millénaire depuis les parents et les
esclaves voilà jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ou dans les entreprises dans
sa poule et justement je dirais que je
suis parti du principe non pas que les
pyramides est permis mais qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être on va parler de pyramide
inversée vraiment inversion des
tendances
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus l'équipe qui
est au service du chef
mais justement où c'est le leader c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on parle de plus
en plus de services leaders le leader
qui est au service de son équipe
vraiment ça va être son équipe qui va
être là du coup à à vouloir en tout cas
avancé et le leader le serveur teaser va
être là pour les accompagner pour créer
une vision commune des valeurs communes
les rituels commun est toujours dans
l'optique de les faire grandir et c'est
vraiment en tout cas la raison pour
laquelle je suis personnellement
convaincu la hiérarchie est ternie et
toujours dans cet état d'esprit de le
faire grandir
chacun est progressivement on s'est
aperçu que la la frontière entre 10 pro
et perso s'est amenuisé
de plus en plus jusqu'à en tout cas
personnellement j'y crois jusqu'à être
complètement terminée bout ce sera cette
base line qu'on a chez nous au work is
not the job c'est à dire que ensemble
voilà on va partager mais on va partager
que du travail
c'est jusqu'à il n'y a pas si longtemps
c'est encore le cas je pense dans
beaucoup d'entreprises en france et dans
le monde
ou carrément d'être interdit de
l'utiliser les réseaux sociaux pendant
la journée pendant les heures de travail
en tout cas c'est quelque chose en tout
cas pour moi qui est un concept nuit tu
vois pas comment on pourrait on pourrait
interdire et justement il s'agit d'un
globez tout ça est de se dire que dans
l'entreprise qui peuvent être
considérées comme chez nous comme une
famille justement on va englober tous
ces rituels là on va on va englober ces
moments dans lesquels on va prendre du
plaisir
on va englober du coup effectivement
comme vous pouvez voir sur les sur les
poteaux du on a des moments de plaisir
des moments de ces deux soirées du fun
des événements sportifs
on va vraiment essayer effectivement de
tout inclure pour avoir quelque chose de
global et pour prendre du plaisir
ensemble
et du coup je vais vous faire une petite
petite anecdote la 2e à la famille sur
quelque chose qui s'est passée comme
vous voyez vous avez effectivement en
eau des personnes qui sont masqués et en
fait il ya à peu près un an
on a organisé un événement week end peu
comme vous avez souvent effectivement
mes week end
étudiant il est prévu de passer un bon
week-end ensemble de s'amuser et en fait
les inscriptions s'arrêter un mois avant
le début du week end est en fait deux
semaines avant le début il y avait 150
personnes qui s'étaient inscrites
et puis il ya vingt personnes qui sont
arrivées comme ça dans les deux
dernières semaines en disant voilà nous
aussi on veut venir et puis la personne
en charge de gérer l'événement m'a
appelé en me disant comment on fait il
n'ya plus classe dotée elle prit place
nulle part on doit annuler leur place un
peu qu'on peut pas les faire venir et ma
réponse a été en une famille est ce que
dans une famille en exclu des membres
est ce que si pour le repas de noël ya
quelqu'un qui arrive en retard elle
combat les sept ans apporte
est-ce que s'il n'était pas prévu qu'il
vienne et ils viennent est ce qu'on va
lui dire le nom n'y a pas de place pour
toi ce soir là non on baltard venir et
justement c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
faire et du coup j'ai envoyé à 22h ce
soir là un mail à tout le monde en
disant voilà pour ceux qui sont
intéressés de vivre une aventure
différente et de me suivre les yeux
fermés il ya une chambre ninety nine et
dans cette chambre effectivement mots
mais voilà ni l'idée c'est de vivre une
aventure donc s'ils vont peut-être
confiance venu il ya deux ans je trouve
que 15 minutes plus tard il y avait
les 20 places étaient prises mais en
plus trente personnes qui étaient en
liste d'attenté et on a vécu un week-end
extraordinaire évidemment les pas de
place dans les hôtels donc qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on n'a pas dormi on a on a
créé des start up
on a deux qu'on a fait des démos
certains projets ont été suivies on
n'avait plus la fête encore que les
autres on a fait du sport on a fait
plein de choses et ça a été une
expérience entre nous tu as été
extraordinaire encore plus
extraordinaire que tous les autres qui
ont passé un bon week-end aussi et à
l'issue de ce qui s'est passé c'est
cette année on a fait un nouveau week
end et tous ceux qui étaient là l'année
dernière on dit on va on veut vivre une
expérience similaire aller encore plus
loin et on veut pas s'arrêter juste au
8ème
on a envie d'être les gardiens de la
culture parce que ce qu'on a vécu tout
ce qu'on a partagé ensemble c'est
vraiment pour nous quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et ça représente bien
notre culture à nous une culture qui est
une culture différente
une culture qui est la nôtre parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a aucune aucune
recette miracle c'est plutôt qu'ils vont
rester intéressant c'est que toutes sont
inspirés et pas forcément de la même
chose et dans l'histoire dit on va être
les cultures activistes ou même les
cultures bar hjorth de cette entreprise
de cette famille est donc non seulement
effectivement on a passé un excellent
week-end ensemble on a vécu une autre
histoire mais en plus cette équipe là
personne ne sait qu'ils sont donc c'est
une organisation secrète chez nous qui
travaillent sur des projets là aussi
secret mais par contre qu'ils ont pour
objectif de maintenir la culture d'être
les garants des valeurs garante de nos
rituels et est vraiment qu'ils qui ont
vraiment cette ambition et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est venu de même et
qui a vraiment en tout cas aujourd'hui
sa place chez nous et qui est
extrêmement fort
et poussard est venue de comme je disais
tout à l'heure de 20 ans d'expérience
souvent lorsqu'on entend parler des
entrepreneurs évidemment pas regarder
que les succès c'est bien regarder les
succès ça permet effectivement de
s'inspirer
mais en réalité ce soit pour moi et je
pense pour la majorité des entrepreneurs
que je connais c'est surtout beaucoup de
feuilles et on prend un entrepreneur on
parle de leader des leaders de demain et
les leaders sont ceux aussi comme je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de servir
une teaser mais surtout ce sont ceux qui
vont prendre des risques mais risque de
fait il est évidemment chez nous on est
les premiers à un mettre en avant non
seulement les succès mais aussi et
surtout les feuilles
pourquoi parce qu'à partir du moment où
quelqu'un a fait l'essai qu'il a essayé
qu'il a testé et ça fait partie
aujourd'hui ta culture et ça fait partie
d'une culture qui est une culture comme
je le disais tout à l'heure une culture
très familiale et pour revenir à ce que
je vous disais en préambule
j'ai un rêve de changer le monde du
travail
et lorsqu'on a un rêve effectivement si
on veut aller au bout il faut aussi
avoir un plan et le plan c'est ce que je
viens de vous expliquer notamment blanc
c'est ce que je viens de vous expliquer
ces dernières minutes à travers deux
anecdotes et puis deux le sont également
et c'est en tout cas les valeurs tiré de
la famille qui vont faire que je peux
arriver à réussir en blanc et je compte
bien réussir et je vais terminer en vous
demandant encore de fermer les yeux
quinze secondes et de vous projeter à
nouveau et je vous demandais quel est
votre rêve pour 2050
quel est votre plan et enfin quel leader
est ce que vous aimeriez être merci